the vaticans has this morning that  retired Pope Benedict's health is  worsening and Pope Francis is asking the  faithful to pray for him the pope  Emeritus is 95 years old he's been  retired since 2013 when he became the  first leader of the Roman Catholic  Church to resign in nearly 600 years  Benedict said at the time that his  declining physical and mental health  made it necessary for him to step down  the last time he was seen in public was  four weeks ago receiving an award this  morning Pope Francis told visitors at  his Wednesday audience that Benedict is  quote very sick a spokesperson says  Francis visited the pope Emeritus  afterward